فرحه عارمه المشهد مشهد استثنائي لم يسبق
له مزيد
هناك احتفالات واسعه
تحريك الكاميرات لنقل جزء من الاحتفال هذه
الليله في اكبر مدن المغرب همم الاناشيد
الوطنيه الاعلام الوطنيه همم الكل يعبر
على طريقته بفرحته همم الرقص من اساليب
التعبير عن هذه والغناء من اساليب التعبير
لدى سكان الدار البيضاء همم نحن همم كمان
نلاحظ هناك اجراءات امنيه في مختلف انحاء
المدينه لتنظيم حركه السير وهي صعبه في
هذه الليله الاستثنائيه في الدار
مره اخرى لان انا امام لوحه فنيه كبيره من
الاحتفالات في الدرب البيضاء
نحرك همم
ليرى المشاهدون الشارع اللي وراء
المشاهدين والشارع وبعد ذلك تعود ايضا الى
الحشود التي اجتمعت في الساحه المقابله
لباب مراكش
هذه كما ترون هذه هذه الشارع الرئيسي في
منطقه باب مراكش الى ممكن تقترب اكثر اذا
ممكن حاول همم
الان هذه الحشود التي وصلت الى قلبي الدار
البيضاء مرشحه للتزداد بحشود مماثله او
اكثر خلال الساعات القادمه
من قلب مدينه دار البيضاء وهي احدى المدن
الرئيسيه في المغرب حيث هذه الاحتفالات
الواسعه والحياه
تركيز على الناس تركيز على الناس الانت من
الساحه الى الشارع الذي يمر من امام باب
مراكش همم نحن في كلب اكبر مدن المغرب همم
سكان البيضاويون سكان الدار البيضاء
يعتبرون ان المغرب ان منتخب المغرب ممثل
المغرب في هذا المونديال لم يخيب امالهم
انه كان عند مستوى تطلعات المغاربه همم
كان هناك جهد كبير سمكه هذه المشاركه
المغربيه لاستثنائيه في مونديال قطر لا
حولنا اهتماما رسميا على اعلى مستوى
بتشجيع المنتخب المغربي
وبمواكبته هناك فرحه عامه ليس ليس في ليست
في الدار البيضاء فقط وانما في كل المدن
المغربيه حتى في مدن الصحراء التقارير همم
التي تصلنا من العيون ومن همم
الداخله ومن السماره همم تحدث عن فرحه
عامه وعن احتفالات شعبيه غير مسبوقه همم
كما تلاحظين الكل يرتدي العلامه الوطنيه
وهناك كثيرون ايضا يرتدون الازياء
التقليديه والكل يعبر بطرقته عن فرحته
بهذا النصر التاريخي